what do you do when you fail and how do
you handle it
what do you do when you fail you know
recently we reviewed that US Army Field
Manual on here from like World War 2 era
and it says in that manual it says other
than death
all failure is psychological other than
death all failure is psychological think
about that just just just think about
that this failure this upset this this
catastrophe if you aren't dead then it's
just psychological it's in your head now
this does not mean that you won't lose
some battles because you will we all
will
but it does mean that as long as you
don't surrender as long as you don't
give up as long as you don't quit then
you haven't failed just means you've
made a a temporary tactical retreat
means you've made a a brief withdraw so
that you can regroup and we attack so
as far as I'm concerned if you get beat
unless you're dead you are not defeated
and you have not failed what you've done
is you've learned you've you've gained
experience and you're still alive and
you have memories to make so get up and
go get after it